(upbeat music)
- I see y'all over there.
Alright, that was really good.
Alright, alright.
I always try to close the show
leaving a smile on our face.
This is what I'm liking y'all.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
For Kids in theater can be
a life-changing experience
opening up new worlds and emotions.
The same is also true
for those living on the autism spectrum.
That's why a Philadelphia
theater has created
a unique drama program that
helps people on the spectrum
foster empathy and create
tools for expression.
We have the Executive Artistic
Director of Theater Horizon
on the line right now,
along with the Director
of Community Investment,
they watch on NBC10 Philadelphia.
Everybody say hello to
Nell and Mydera, hi.
(audience cheering)
- Hey.
- Hi, everyone.
- Nice to see y'all.
So how did this all get started, Nell?
- Sure. Yeah, so Theater Horizon,
we're always trying to find
new ways to help people
feel like the theater is for them.
And 18 years ago,
we had a really unique
opportunity to do that.
Some parents came to us
after their son just
had an autism diagnosis,
which people talked about
a lot less 18 years ago.
And they wanted to
build his social skills,
his emotional intelligence
and so we built a program
from the ground up.
It started with one kid
and now 18 years later,
we have 60 kids who work
with us throughout the year.
It's been a transformative
experience for their families
and I'm really proud of
the fact that actually
six of our autism drama
students just performed
in our last professional production.
- Oh, my gosh.
(audience cheering)
Can I just say, you
didn't have to say yes,
you know what I'm saying?
You could have said, "Oh,
we don't provide that."
You could have said,
"Oh, I'm so sorry we
don't have that here."
But you didn't, you reworked
everything to accommodate
and because of that, your whole life grows
and changes in the way you didn't expect.
And that's a beautiful thing.
I just want to commend you
both on that, that's amazing.
So Mydera, explain how it works.
(audience cheering)
- Sure thing.
Typically our program
runs three times a year,
in the fall, spring, and in the summer.
Our students can join us in-person
or they can tune in on
our virtual classes,
really whatever way they feel
most comfortable to engage.
And then through theater
games, creative play,
interaction and improv, we
create a social environment
where our students are
encouraged to further
their social relationships,
grow their social skills
and flexible thinking
and find new and creative
ways to express themselves.
And these are the type of
skills that are fundamental
when you're talking
about social engagement
and social interaction.
And we know there are theater games
and our opportunities to have
this time with our student,
they are monumental in making sure
that moments and realizations like this
for that particular student and
so many others are possible.
- Man, teaching a kid the
skill of how to communicate
how they feel on the
inside is so invaluable.
So many kids do have
a hard time with that.
That's such an incredible
gift that you're giving
and such an incredible opportunity too.
And helping these
parents, this is so cool.
Thank you so much, Nell.
Thank you Mydera.
(audience cheering)
I'm liking your posts right
now, I'm loving y'all even more.
(audience cheering)
So that's not all though.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable
and incredible people just like y'all.
So they're gonna be
writing Theater Horizon
a check for $1,000, how's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- My gosh.
- Oh, my goodness.
- Thank you so much.
- Absolutely ladies.
(audience cheering)
Y'all have a blessed day, we love y'all.
We can't wait to hear more
from your organization.
This is such a cool thing that y'all do.
Thank you so much for hanging with us
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Alexander Daddario, Justin
Guarini, Michael Kim, Gabby
and Tauren Wells, y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.